hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trading census.com so in this video i
would like to go with you guys through
yesterday's press action on gamestop i
mean friday and thursday price action we
have some interesting information here
coming from the market so let's analyze
this and see what it means for the next
moves let's get into it
[Music]
alright so let me recap here a bit the
situation so like i was saying in my
yesterdays and today's gme recap on my
discord that i post every day guys i was
telling you that you know we have here
so let me zoom in a little bit we have
here this breakout on the short term all
right so i have here a wedge pattern
what is the watch pattern is a pattern
where you have those trend lines
converging but both going lower this
wouldn't be a wedge this would be a
triangle like this the wedge is a
reversal pattern and usually because the
market is making new lows and usually
you have the momentum that is shifting
because it's making new laws but you
know it's like you know this trend land
is converging towards the swan it's not
expanding so it's the moves are lighter
and here we have this divergence on our
lithium frame okay and we have it on the
flowers
we have it on the three hours that is
completely useless and we have it on the
flowers that is great okay let's see if
we have it on the daily if we have three
okay we don't have it on the daily you
can see here the magazine is going lower
but we already have it on the four hours
and on the hourly time frame which is
for me good enough to say that this will
impact positively the press action for
the coming two weeks just like we have
for amc here the situation is a bit
similar for me amc will be leading the
path because everything is happening on
amc these days so maybe it will get back
to gme and then amc will follow gme but
for now it's the other way around so a
picture of amc helps well to understand
what jamie might do and here it's
basically a bit doing the same patterns
once again driven by amc
so here we have this short-term breakout
guys and for now it's holding all right
so just connect the highs here and here
this is a breakout why because here i
can see that i have a stronger volume so
let's check on the hourly time frame you
see we have here stronger volume
associated to this candle so the
breakout candle so this is telling me
that there is some resistance at this
level that has been uh overcome and now
we are consolidating around the 160
level we close above which is good guys
this is a pivot point for me so every
week you close above 160 is a good
signal
for the coming week so here i'm happy to
have 162 closing level now let's start
to analyze a bit let's do some idiot
wave theory
so once again this is what i'm trying to
do guys it's not easy but on the longer
term it's working pretty well and we
have here one two three four five and we
want to know between the one and the
third if the ratio makes sense and here
it's you know it it makes sense to go to
the 0.618 once again i get it from here
guys you just click elliott wave theory
frost and pressure on google
you know this i've shown that to you
guys many many times you tap
fibonacci in here you go quite far all
right here we go
so you can see that for the fifth wave
here
when you divide 0.618 by 0.382
you come up with 0.618 again so this is
the configuration i am checking and it
means that the fifth wave equals 0.618
times one plus three which is here
happening so it makes sense for a fixed
wave so discounting would be valid and
once again yes this is what i'm gonna
try to do when i'm gonna take live
training uh it's september with gabriel
who is the trader that joined trading
census two weeks ago so i take the
opportunity here to tell you that guys
you have one more day where i keep some
discounted prices then prices will go up
because i don't want too many people and
we're gonna create i think something
unique that uh i don't know if any other
youtubers doing we're gonna share with
you guys all the details of our trades
before making the trades and we will
follow up with everything that is
happening so we're going to tell you for
example oh we're going to change the
stop loss to the entry level so we don't
lose money here we're going to update
the targets we're going to you know use
all the techniques that we know how to
use that we are telling you how to use
but we're going to show you this is my
project so join if you are interested
and applying those methods to gamestop
is actually telling me that here the 200
level for me the 185 level is the next
resistance level so i'm very curious to
know what will happen here and once
again it will depend a lot of amc on the
other hand i have a support level at 135
that is very strong so here we have the
battle is not happening yet you see amc
is already in the kind of bear camp gme
is not so jimmy has more room maybe to
develop on the upside so let's see and
below 135 it's not looking good at all
guys it will probably go to 85 okay at
the next support level so here there is
a zone that we need to keep in mind is
dangerous but for now we are far from it
and we are rather developing on the
upside so this is looking good to me and
if we break 190 then everything can
happen as it should all right we should
be finishing this
correction that is extremely long but
you know fair enough those kind of moves
sometimes they take a lot of time to
complete
and then we are waiting for a last move
up i mean last i don't know but next
move up that would probably go to 800 if
we managed to break this bear trend that
is happening since jan alright so there
are two levels 185 and then we have the
260 level roughly above that it looks of
course very good so let's find out let's
see what happens i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys